yeah so for Ingo Yale I allowed myself
to change the title then the one written
in the program this is more advanced Oh
general theorem so I'm going to pick up
a tie pilot repetition tuned for
partially simulated al you might want to
explain parsley what it is if he has
mood kale divergence this joint work
with my former student ty Berman in my
current student idiots video so this
talk is about also what to say that this
is thank you for staying even moolies
here Dean say so because even in
tel-aviv it's not that easy to do so any
oh so just talking about Allan
solidification and what is our
interpretation is one of the most basic
tasks in computation the study of
computation telling a weekly are the
primitive into hard one okay now most
examples you know if you're
cryptographers a week with this
two-on-one a function or puzzles if
you're a complexity theorist then worst
case - average case it had some
functions languages and if you care
about protocols this introducing some
say of interactive proof finger proved
many perverts and the what the focus of
this talk is what call interactive
argument on computational soundproof
this has proved the soundness on your
old games polynomially bounded day
it's a watering talk document you all
know it what it they are with us that we
quickly there's a portal and verifying
the statement the verifier either accept
or reject and we said that this protocol
is better soundness
if you invalid statement and arbitrary
efficient over the probability that
makes the verify accept is it most
better typically you would lock better
to be negligible but sometimes don't get
it directly and get better I say well
laughs and then we want to amplify so
good about a apart from being form
talked about and being interactive
argument which you care about for bogey
something about language but if you
think about it then the the security
aspect of many security aspects of many
cryptographic primitive can be cast as
the soundness arrow of interactive
argument for instance you can you have a
commitment scheme so The Binding of the
commitment can be cast on a self
inductive argument or related in a
fragment and therefore if you find
methods to improve a sound level of
inductive argument in the military apply
methods will prove say the security of
the binding of statistical argument so
there are more care about and
simplification target ultimate is more
than only for argument it's also further
point
good so the focus of this talk is
amplification of inductive argument
namely to find a generic or fully simple
transformation they take the take it
reduces on a self protocol for argument
so we starting with a with a some
arguments a sound a 0 is 1/2 I want to
transfer to different argument 2007 or
say is negligible this is the goal and
again with active generic confirmation
replies to any argument and to maintain
the properties of the original protocol
don't want to follow the protocol give a
new protocol rather I would like
transformation that it's almost the very
simple thing maintain additional
properties of support
so you know ask any kids and you tell
you it is something is add some without
doing many times becomes very hard right
we all know it and in particular it
means that what could know in this
repetition or that you repeat if you
want to prove something that's prove it
many times independently so the verifier
is independent and the most natural way
to do that is via what you call
sequential repetition namely the poop
that verify that this thing means call
that when it and approve it again again
again again in only if it's exceeding
all these sequential interaction the
verify excellent so it's the question of
the position to reduce unstable in the
in the notice the time annual so in
almost any computational mode okay it's
always walks okay and in optimal rate in
the rate that you cannot improve better
than mourners if they wish and soundness
was minus Epsilon you cannot opt get
more than one minus epsilon to the power
of normal for British South Asian
sequential opposition is the solution
very simple everything is great in any
computational model but as you can see
the disadvantage is the run complexity
block good so why not do parallel
petition okay it's the second most
nights were thing to do and you see it's
definitely preserve the run complexity
okay so the question is does it improve
security right we expect to but the very
surprising question is the answer is
that not in general there are protocols
which if someone said oh one half and
you repeated many times in parallel in
some some nacelle remain one half this
is the very nice example of counter
example a believer in palliative now
from 97 describe it using safe but you
can think that safe or commitment to
David Lough encryptions so the verifier
flips a bit and put inside a safe and
send the safe to the poor just stupid
example but is that so what should be
its counter example so an approval issue
this put this different date
beep I'm and send it over to the very
now the verifying sends the key to the
pool the pool sends the key is key to
the verify the verify opened the safe
because you got the key and very checked
whether B prime equal B and not only
that it checked that the safe got back
from the pool is not the same safe is
sent to the over without otherwise I'll
simply Playa and if this is the case yes
you see the only thing that proves to do
is sensei a constant value or a no value
you cannot win more than probability one
ours but it can win probability one-half
by the simply put in a random way this
is the example now let Elektra put it in
twice in parallel okay so two
independent verify put two independent
bits inside a safe they say first enter
the power and what approver does though
so you've never seen this example in
this example no okay so what do I do
so the switch and now the verifier sends
the kids in easy to notice that the very
both very far except if the first beat
is equal to the second beat which opens
with probability 1/2 and notice that
it's verify is happy because the safe it
received from the poor is different for
the one it sent soundness was one of you
repeated twice soundlessly 1/2 and it
can be generalized to any number of
repetition and modern-day pietà that
will some soul that exists a single
protocol structured for any number for
nom nom of repetition the sound
necessarily remain 1/2 the it's not like
that if you repeat enough time then the
issue of coming a communication go
plastic you know the single protocol any
number of Pournami repetition
yes only because the the imitation is
the proven its computation about it
it doesn't go and for good reason
because partition does work for sync
approval like what's called all-powerful
so repetition does improve soundness in
many many interesting cases absolutely
probably in most cases that most people
here care about okay so free message
argument this was so very same work but
I believe and clear to no public oral
argument was a verifier simply sends
random coins in each round this was
first shown but I stirred past yet a
second will extol improve by channeling
glue and then simply pour the same
optimal result by a scientist also to
for single poof uh poof namely they
regions on several worlds against
all-powerful prover also 4-tuple
Whoville proof this more complicated
started by rather than improvement but
Ornstein Rao it's at one and for the
random termination variant of any
argument and next line going to explain
what what it means this I showed a ten
years ago and also for partially
simulated argument this is a
generalization of such argument
considered by a third person at all and
finally if you take the original
argument and compile it using fhe then
politician also walk but this is a
conditional result unity assume for the
most encryption on more than that you
basically who in the region protocol so
if the witch import will say was fair
the new protocol is not fair any longer
okay so the focus of this talk is this
random termination a variance so what is
is you getting any argument okay
I'm round down to me the new verify
doesn't verify the new verify does the
following in each round Philip bitcoins
and probability one over m it's one and
if it's one it adds an accept ok second
round does the same flip a coin probably
one over m it's hard and accept God's
ability to reaches the end and therefore
it does like what they accept if they
were generally fired it's almost the
same portal okay slightly it changed the
sound set of slightly change the verify
but all the
the pot everything almost intact okay if
it was fair it's fairly cozy do whatever
you like and I show the ten years ago
that Pamela petition of whatever
protocol you start argument you start to
do it if you do this a tweak then
parallel petition does improve some in
exponential rate
the downside that exponential rate is
not the one you like you would like to
have one nice epsilon to the K like in
public or non free message argument etc
but you pay a factor of in exponent of M
to the 4 over epsilon mean meaning that
you need to know a lot of repetition to
make
so the goal of this talk is to improve
this analysis the same argument don't
touch the argument owning the pooled
analysis
so I result to give a tight analysis of
a partner position of a variant and we
prove it to a 1 minus epsilon not the K
we pay fact of M in the X rather so it's
M over cube over epsilon improvement
compared to V tilde yes but you think
about epsilon T that's almost a thing
yes number phone so Amy's number form of
the protocol so Amy's number found and
then the verify Hertz would be to 1 over
a minute so omitting generalize to what
called parsley stimulated protocol
almost I mean going to say something
what was passed its money to protocol
but it's almost a generalized today i
decent requirement for the original
definition and not as important we defer
you develop new tool to analyze what we
called the name many rounds could embed
an execution I'm going to explain what
it is waterproof
and we believe that this this tool is
rather this such a distribution rather
natural involved it is still going to be
fine additional application and forward
speaker question this is essentially
give a lower bound showing that for
random termination variant this a
misadventure
there is a protocol do only improves
like that one minus epsilon to the K
over m a difficult is can you do a
different transformation no to do the
random termination if you go for the
land of domination this is tight
no but so yeah so if you're a reporter
called you start with a portico okay you
consider it's random combination in
their new repetition
okay finger that the epsilon between the
wizard protocol in the new and the
validation holds the same okay they
sound a stable salman's thing so we
start with the protocol you do the
random termination do parallel petition
then the sound cell is the best this is
the Optima if you start to the protocol
do different tricks say do fully move
encryption or protocol then you do para
la petition you get the better you might
keep you know it should be one of em is
it going so it doesn't work at all okay
one of them square it's almost never
helped and then you're dead okay should
be one of them one of them seems to be
the optimum but we saw if you one of
them it's easy to see that you have to
go for out of him okay and if you go for
larger than the soundest arrow it's all
solved and there's no sound and say oh I
mean and you go for smaller one then you
don't approve that with the same like
the original protocol so whenever is
optimized black box
black box Oh
unconditional they've turned to the
unconditional but if it public or you
don't need this result you have a public
already public wants walk immediately so
can ever
ofHe doesn't seem like the right
solution for me because it conditional
but again the onus entire if you have
more should ask you before actually is
the only way we know to amplify this
that is glide the commitment in around
four seven remaining is using this so
you can so if we want to amplify
satisfied commitment and you have fully
more encryption then doesn't make sense
probably can use it to get committed to
in but we have static I'll commit the
only it around reserved reduction easier
this way
good so how do we prove that
so started sure that they're not more
general father I'm to proving a partner
petition of protocol etcetera and then
I'm going to show what its failed for
arbitrary protocol and what goes good
for a random termination one
so the general paradigm is we are
lifting as liad else said yesterday I
had a stupid comment why lifting this
indeed lifting so why is it lifting it's
a similar protocol so this is not random
termination I'll be to the protocol we
Sunnis areas one on epsilon and assume
some PK star wins the K fold a game with
probability more than epsilon pi think
that epsilon prime is very small in one
man epsilon it's almost we'd like to
prove that this cannot be we would like
to use this K fold pick a style for
building pistol between the single game
and why is it lifting because PK style
might win per bit one of a million its
above than what we should have but it's
very very small and P star should win
probability almost one so we should
leave this very small probability to get
a very high probability and this is a
versatile lifting typically and also it
requires something in non-trivial not
like reduction it we take something plug
it in and you get the result no we take
something you work very hard and then
hopefully you get relief there is one
probability which is above than what it
should have to very high probability
so the way happens both in the sim
approval and in the multiple it's
slightly different but in a naturally
you know in the bird eye view is is the
same so we have this K fault over that
does too well on the K repetition okay
and you would like to use it to win a
single repetition so what do you do so a
single instance you have your a you pick
one of the verify at random and you
going this verify going to be plagued by
a single instance verify okay and the
other very files you have to play by
yourself in other words the the new
Hoover's is emulated the K fault Pavel
and the rest of the verified the the
honest valid file without knowing that
it is playing actually the I've verified
now when this I verify is saying the
message you know you forward it to the K
for the pool but expecting care K
question not a single one so you summit
and if you the crux of the issue you
simply stand what choose the rest of the
questions feed them to the pool
II give you K answer and you take the
eyes of those and send it to verify all
the issue in this run determination
proof or a nice parent petition a proof
is how to choose this emulated verifying
a question okay you can assume with that
of the generality in this case that
Hoover is deterministic so everything is
deterministic but they dancers the way
of the emulator
you're very liberal so okay so how do
you choose them so the basically it is
very simple okay you get the first
question from the from the from the real
verified in your view is the I've
methods of the I've verified and then
you sample a random unique that
occlusion consistent with this message
okay you choose all the other methods of
the verified in all rounds not only in
this round but also in future round till
you get a random win exact equation
maybe you have to do it many time I
eventually you do you'll get the
randomization with I've method in the
first round is this one got from the
real verified and then you set the first
round message of the emulated verify to
the method sent in these winning is also
the iPhone and this is they know you
could not always do that okay you have a
little also your verify which is rather
easy but also the emulated verify
without is a limit you cannot submit
just wait a minute let me tell you in
the future
no how can you so sometimes you can
something on okay that's one say if you
can if you unbounded Western bad can
this what happening and all that prove
you can do that they this white panel a
petition of of proofs go for so let me
be so let's do a okay so is this a good
attack yes in any model okay if you
manage to do that but can be carried out
depends Samsung you can if it's under
the proof you can because you have a
unbounded as well if it's public owned
you can if it's under fully morphic
Egyptian you can but generally might not
so let's move public on case which is
the case you can because what happened
is attack the verify sends some that's
random coin you switch and you know you
never know emulation step you go to
choose a random random continuation if
it's winning you want to pick it up
duper Jackson sampling otherwise you do
it again
you know continue continue and know that
you need to you need to sample then the
next method of the real verify but in
public coins very easy because the
method that are simply independent
Dunham coin so you can do that very
easily and that's so in public coin you
can very easily implement if vandal it
Jackson sampling so I'm going to soon
explain what goes wrong in non-public
one you can notice that but let me just
before that say something about are
doing you analyze this okay so that's
one thing about notation you can think
about all the messages in the mattress
this is like this is the first message
of all K verified this is second makes
it all calculated in one of this column
is the one sent by the river okay and
that will just event over this
everything is in the domestic beside the
method SW is the event winning a event
over this method that namely the case
where the old all verify accept okay so
now we're the matrix of all the method
that sent by the k-fold protocol all the
mo good so the task is given a given the
J's method of life verifier you need to
sample in this term you need to sample
from this distribution name we do su the
random method that is consistent with
the path consistent with eyes method in
this round and is the winning in this
winning okay so this is the task this in
this matrix time this is the task in
hand okay this is what you need to do
it's nothing
that's just notation why is the same
like what what it does is quite good so
how to analyze the success probabilities
attack so first we sky what is they
called the real the real distribution
distribution over this matrix induced by
the attacker I just described
okay random quotation etcetera and now
we also consider what called ideal
distribution it is just random winning
mattress okay random mean limit is there
are no cards tip in which all the if I
accept
and not the only difference this is
always the same if you rewrite them the
only difference is that the eyes message
in the real execution on the real
distribution is chosen uniformly by the
real verify we're in the ideal execution
this ice method is choosing condition on
winning okay
only the difference in the way the ice
method is chosen every okay so now we
look at ideal it is very simple in
particularly deal or verify always
accept
so if matters to show the trail is close
to a deal it means it's also in real all
verify always accept namely the in
particular the ice that if I accept
namely that exactly it's very nice
palette I'm probably using many many
many places in the equipt on complexity
few ways to find a different
distribution which is typically easier
to analyze various done a somewhat going
on and then to compare the real
distribution the ideal so every walk of
us that the Tod so as it'll actually
measure the statistical distance between
this solution and this yield untied
result okay and my early walking on
determination also consider the
statistical is what chunk and passed it
in really beautiful walk they measured
they found the KL divergence between
distribution because of bout the K
diversion which better measure for this
for the settings they get it I decide
what is the best version very roughly is
the expected low colosseo between the
distribution route expectation you
support in taking over the left-hand
side
five more minutes so we supposed to
understand with this w is the winning
the winning case they'll case it's all
verify except that will you this term
this is small but W is that the event
will all it winning transcript Oliver if
I accept in all in all no executions
w is everything is defined it doesn't
matter just Tran Tran ski W is a
basically it's a subset of all possible
transmit you get a transcript you know
if it's winning or not W is that's a
subset of possible can't sleep good so
so much for that
it is probably to expect to a
probability we spec today the case where
the prover wins greatest probability
every wind of the k of day of the K run
over it's not of a set or a deal what we
actually do respect to the uniform
distribution good the W is the event we
sped to the uniform distribution that
the cape over winds in which we assume
is too large
okay good so once this probably get well
you get the wall see that and should
expect it eventually if the pupal is
doing only probability 1 or 2 minus 1
minus epsilon to the K there are sets
over namely the one that play
independently which of the day of the
execution so you have to play this
winning probability small it get your
result get worse and you expect that the
more repetition you better demand sure
because you repeat more you expected to
improve better so again this this value
is does not really matter for now that's
the key issue is that we bound KL
divergence and not statistical distance
why care the Virgin's for several reason
so first you know Caldwell's was used I
think in cryptography similar setting
many times think first world I am way
off
is that a lasted from Oh a one on
ninety-one so from 91 and very roughly
sorry for those information fewest among
you it's more subtle than the
statistical distance particular their
settings were statistical distance is
the same for two different distribution
well actually it is very different case
so when you have bound of care divergent
you know more about the actual distance
between the distribution second-stage a
calibration the chain rule which is
extremely useful when dealing with the
distribution induced by particles okay
which are iteratively utility we defined
a deferred what also very nice vehicle
diverges X is estimate
because we take the expectation we spent
to the left and distribution and a very
roughly again you need to understand
more it suffice Audrina sent more about
P and not that much about Q okay well in
our case P is ideal which is very simple
we really understand it
use the real distribution which is a
mess which you don't understand but
because it's carry diversion we are we
are fine okay but the problem would kill
the Virgin's that it's a AG mainly you
know it does some region that no one
cares about it's up in very small
probability thing go wrong and then you
dead okay you cannot use it this the
reason that it's not that when it work
is great when it doesn't work you have
to go back to difficulties so I won't
get just let's just mention that
rejection so now let's go back what goes
wrong with non-public coins what goes on
non-public coin that you cannot do
rejection something for instance and
feel to the verified effect yeah
so if there's some small probability
event that makes the verifier reject
negligible probability event and the
original protocol then the KL divergence
is going to be infinite because that
will happen with the negligible
probability in your real distribution
and it will never happen in your ideal
no it's fine it's fine
so it's mean I didn't know because you
measure couldn't ideal and I did it
always wins the ideal it always been
yeah for in many other cases but in
particular there so it's not yeah so
that's quick well why so we leave the
analyte analysis for a second then go
back to the for very short time but why
this approach does not work for non
public one protocol doesn't work in
general because this random calculation
or rejection sampling might be very
impossible actually for computation
about entities and think they're very
sorry this tells message commit to a bit
B and then you would like to do this
rejection sampling you know to do
continuation to protocol if you could it
mean that you open the encryption or
open the commitment which you cannot
because the commitment is thank you just
cannot do that what you can do well the
only thing you can do is defend I did
mind you can do is assume that this ice
verify about if it's about well
definitely you can simply the future
because there's no future okay so we
sample conditioned if it's a boy so you
Mendez do sample may now you screw the
distribution it's not the right
distribution unless they verify about
anyhow even with this very small
probability and then we still scoot the
distribution but many hopefully know
that better and this what happened in
the random termination and with the say
one I skip that they say that what what
we managed to do so actually we try to
do the pose of a convenient path and it
turns out that to use K diversion it
turns out the K diverges in the setting
of the school distribution might be
infinite actually you cannot do that
rather we could consider relaxed version
of a scale divergence so what relaxed
version we like some some version that
is not a sensitive to small events the
most dirty one natural a natural
approach is to walk like when you smooth
the amine entropy is namely to take the
infimum of a failed of distribution that
are statistical cost of the wizard
exhibition they tend to be bad choice
for several reason but first because you
are back to using a certificate decent
immune to understand you very well the
right hand side which we cannot and
second a it does not exploit the again
may be the same reason different
different way to express it it doesn't
use the a symmetric way of of k
divergence we need to know more about
the left hand side and the left about
the writers so what we do ain't going to
end here we reduce I'm sure people
thought about it for this definition but
it worked so good for our settings so
I'm not claiming that we invent
something new which I think that for
this and it seemed like the right choice
we consider following variant of a
smooth divergence which again the
infimum in call it epsilon smoothly
diversity diversity is the infimum over
some random function applied to the
original distribution such that it's
random function first
if either output the same in the input
or output something outside of the
domain this is a technical part and the
left hand side the left hand side
function output input with probability
savored probability of C so only care
what happened with the left hand side
you totally don't care what kind of the
right hand side is solution so we
maintained is a symmetric a property
that you very we like so much okay so
only car that with respect to the left
hand side distribution a it's the
identity with high probability and just
nice property that mode to speak that
the smooth care divergence between the
real and real distribution
induced by this random termination
attack is very and I believe that
something more general about many routes
could
and not have time to explain the slide
so we give optimal an analysis of
politician for annum termination and
policies monitor protocol and we develop
tool to analyze menu
[Applause]
it seems like you've lost any connection
to kill because that can be yes but it
cannot be what save us is this fact that
either output either output the original
value or it actually something outside
the domain yes
without it it's Nance it doesn't mean
anything but with that mean well you can
do whatever you like
but as long if this is small and we know
that this is a tent without probability
it's mean that this does not happen it
implicitly implies that that because if
the kind of a thing is small and this
happens on probability that actually
this what so deal the queue actually is
also they dilated with a probability but
you don't have to prove that okay
automatically by the finish
thank you
[Applause]